-It does seem as though
one of the things
when you talk about how the rich
are being taken care of,
money is obviously playing
a huge role in politics,
and I feel as though
the Democratic Party
also has to answer for the large
amounts of corporate money
they've taken over the years.
You don't take
corporate PAC money.
-No.
-But do you think that
the Democratic Party
has to take a stronger stand
against taking corporate money,
or is that just the price
of doing business?
-So, look, I have been worried
for a very long time
about the impact of money
in Washington.
You know, money just
doesn't talk in Washington.
It shouts. It screams.
It commands.
But let's never lose sight
of the fact
that the Trump administration
is the most corrupt
administration in our lifetime.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We can't forget it.
And...
And think about
example after example --
that, right now, the Saudis
can funnel money directly --
indirectly into Trump's pockets
through the Trump Hotel...
that the head of the
Environmental Protection Agency
is a coal lobbyist.
And can I tell you
about Gary Cohn?
-Sure. Go for it.
-Yeah. So, here's the deal.
So, Trump is setting up --
Trump is setting up
his administration.
This is a year and a half
ago. He's setting up
his administration.
He brings in all these
Goldman Sachs guys.
I swear to you, they could
have opened a branch office
of Goldman Sachs right there
in the White House.
-And it should be noted,
this is the same Goldman Sachs
that Donald Trump
railed against Hillary Clinton
for giving paid speeches to.
-Exactly that one.
Okay, so, he brings in
these Goldman Sachs people,
but one of them
was very special.
Gary Cohn was a major executive
at Goldman Sachs,
and he is going to be
the special advisor to the
President, economic advisor,
to help get
the tax laws changed.
So Goldman Sachs gives Gary Cohn
a little gift on the way out --
$750 million.
I think of it
as a sort of pre-bribe.
And then Gary Cohn goes off
and writes the tax laws,
helps ram them through Congress,
and Goldman Sachs
makes billions of dollars
off the change in the tax laws.
Let's call this out
for what it is.
Corruption. Pure and simple.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You mentioned --
You mentioned the Saudis.
I also want to ask about this,
because I feel like we are so --
We tend to get so focused
on what's happening in D.C.
and what's specifically
happening with this presidency.
You wrote a letter today,
I believe,
to the commander
of Central Command
about this horrific bombing
in Yemen,
a bombing that killed civilians,
killed children.
This is Saudis. This is the UAE.
But it is U.S.-backed,
in that munitions, in that
refueling and intelligence.
Can you explain a little about
what you asked for
in that letter?
-Sure.
So, this is an unfolding
humanitarian crisis,
and the United States
is not dropping bombs,
but it is helping the Saudis
with arms.
It's helping the Saudis
with refueling.
And it now appears it's helping
the Saudis target and pinpoint.
I think that if the
United States is going to be
that directly involved
in a humanitarian crisis,
then the American people
have a right to know
exactly what's going on.
-I agree with you,
and I'm very glad
that you asked that question.
Hopefully we get answers.
My last question.
Obviously, we have
Justice Kavanaugh --
might-be Justice Kavanaugh.
He is Trump's pick
for the Supreme Court.
-I hope not. Mm-hmm.
-It strikes me
that maybe progressives
are not making
the same push to stop this
that they had made to, say,
stop the repeal of the
Affordable Care Act.
Do you think this is something
that enough effort's
being put behind,
or do you think
it's basically a done deal
and he's going to be
our next justice?
-So, you know, look,
it is not a done deal.
Donald Trump
has made his nomination,
and he picks somebody off a list
that has been prescreened,
prescreened by not one but two
right-wing extremist groups.
-I will say it's just refreshing
that anyone screens someone
that Donald Trump picked.
Usually he just opens the door
and, like, lets in 15 people.
-But not this time.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-Not this time,
because one of the groups,
the founder of the group's
number-one goal
is to overturn Roe vs. Wade.
So think about
what that screen is,
that he made it onto this list.
The other group, very hostile
to government protecting
healthcare for all Americans.
So, just last night,
I was in Boston,
and I got to say we were doing
a Rise Up for Roe,
you know, out there
in the fight.
Because here's the deal
about this.
I remember the night that
Donald Trump was sworn in,
and I remember thinking they --
"Healthcare could disappear
for tens of millions
of Americans by next week
because they now have
the House, they have the Senate,
they have the White House,
they have the votes."
And, I thought, "What have we
got left to fight with?"
And the answer is
all we got left is each other.
We've got the ability to come
together to raise our voices,
to be strong, to fight back,
to make sure that
this Washington hears us.
And over healthcare,
I'm thinking,
"Where do we get this army?"
And the next morning
after the inauguration,
anyone remember the women?
The largest protest rally
in the history of the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So...I get it.
You bet.
Here's what I see happening.
Yeah, Donald Trump
is on the attack,
and he's trying to roll back
protection for women,
Roe vs. Wade,
probably roll back
a lot of other protections
with Judge Kavanaugh's
nomination.
He would be the deciding vote
on all of these critical issues.
But at the very same moment
that Donald Trump
is trying to do this,
democracy itself is changing.
It changed with
the Women's March.
It changed when people
went to the airports
after Trump tried to put
a Muslim ban in place.
It changed when people
went down to Washington --
the mamas of babies
with complex medical needs,
people who use wheelchairs,
who got right up in the face
of the Republican senators.
It keeps changing as more people
come off the sidelines.
15-year-olds and 16-year-olds
after the shooting in Florida
said, "I'm in this fight.
I'm going to make sure
my government hears from me."
So that's what it takes.
And I believe we can do this.
-All right.
Well, have fun at work tomorrow.
-I will.
-I hope you enjoy your return.
Thank you so much
for being back here.
-You bet.
-It's always a pleasure.